[Music]
hey thanks for joining us so my name is
Chad Jennings I'm a product manager for
bigquery and today we're gonna spend a
little bit of our time talking about
geospatial analysis in bigquery and how
our customer geotab has been using that
to supply their customer ie
municipalities with interesting insights
and data I don't know how many people
here went to the spotlight session for
bigquery a little while ago okay a few
so you guys know a secret that not
everybody knows and so keep it to
yourself for a second because I get to
reveal it so we have we have one feature
here to launch that I'm really really
excited about so let's go ahead and get
right to it all right so there are there
are three of us so I'm joined today by
two colleagues from geotab which is a
big query customer and they're going to
be walking you through an application
that they've generated using some of the
features that we're launching here we're
gonna present this session like a play
in three acts so I'll do the setup and
then Bob and Daniel will come on for the
main act and then I'll come up and do
the wrap-up so if you only have
attention for one acts in our play it's
the main act the one in the middle you
can like tune me out for a little bit
but like pay real good attention to the
stuff that geotab talks about because it
is super cool all right
so here we go there are a few things
that we need to know like to get the
demo that geotab is going to show there
a few little bit of background knowledge
I'm assuming that most people have heard
of what bigquery is I'm not going to
dwell on this but query is Google cloud
platforms enterprise data warehouse it
goes super fast over super big data for
more details see like the other 67 talks
on bigquery I did want to dwell on this
one though
and so like GCP has over a hundred
products so there are over a hundred
little blue hexagons and I don't know
about you all but I can get a little bit
lost in amongst them so I wanted to put
this slide up to talk just a shade about
where bigquery sits relative to the
other store
and database products I'm not gonna go
through all of them but you can see that
way over here on the left side is the
data warehouse it's kind of like a
relational data warehouse that can go
over incredibly large volumes of data
real good for analytics and dashboards I
think that's going to be useful to the
folks watching on the video as well to
just have this one as a reference okay
so now we'll get to this so that's a
little bit of like pre work a little bit
of homework now we'll get to the cool
thing so the thing that we're talking
about right now the thing we're
introducing the thing we're really
launching is you know solving this
analysts problem solving their use case
they want to be able to analyze and
visualize geospatial data within
bigquery right now it's possible but
it's not super easy so we're gonna
change that so first a little bit of
background so what's the difference
between a geometry and a geography so
when my kids draw lines on the map they
say oh how do we get from like Seattle
to LA they just like draw a line on the
map right they're doing Euclid although
they don't know it the shortest distance
between two points is a straight line
that is perfectly accurate except if the
surface that you're talking about is
actually curved such as such as our
planet here so in this case the shortest
distance between Seattle and Stuttgart
is this great circle route however
Euclid was not wrong if you look at that
from space you get that straight line
again so the point of this is that if
you want to express geometries on the
surface of the earth obviously you've
got to take the curvature of the earth
into account otherwise you get the math
wrong that's really the whole point of
this so can you properly do GIS in
bigquery using sequel any guesses as to
what I'm done okay right thank you I saw
a couple chuckles in the back so the
answer is yes and that's the capability
that we're launching right now so we are
bringing geospatial data types and
geospatial functions into bigquery as
first-class citizens and that is I mean
like I know there's no fireworks going
on but
that is super cool let's press in a
little bit so this is a 200 level talk
so we're going to get into some details
I'm not going to read all of this but
what we're launching today is native
support for many categories of s T
underscore star function so those of you
who use post GIS will find this very
very comfortable and I put this slide up
here both as reference for like later
viewing and as a an indication that
there really is you know quite a wide
swath of functionality that we're
introducing here right from predicates
to parsers and formatters etc here's a
list
oh sorry here's a list of the data types
that we're supporting so points line
strings polygons polygons with voids in
them Multi polygons and then a
collection is one or any number or any
collections one any number or any
combination of all of these above the
format's were supporting right now are
well-known texts in geo JSON will be
adding support for ingesting shape files
natively really soon here's a list of
some of the functions that we're
launching right now a couple of our
favorites we've got links to queries so
if you've got access to the slides later
on you can just come and click on this
and it'll take you to a bigquery query
where you can play with the join based
on STD within but you know for those of
you who use these kinds of functions or
have used these kinds of functions in
the past you know this should look
pretty familiar and feel pretty familiar
to you anyway we're super super stoked
about that but that's really only half
of the problem right like when you when
you write a query and you you've print
out a geography in the table of you or
portion of the bigquery UI but for
example there are census tracts in their
zip codes that have you know thousands
of vertices and so if you just print out
that row you get a thousand lat/long
pairs like that makes for a very poor
user experience right tables is not how
human beings visualize or interact with
geospatial data and so we have a couple
different options for folks to do viz on
geo data
inside of GCP number one is for hardcore
mappers right you can go ahead and use
earth engine you can export geo data
from bigquery import it into Earth
engine and then use the JavaScript
console which is that middle middle
section of tiny text and right there to
create whatever map you want based on
the data that you just brought in from
bigquery so for hardcore mappers like so
first off it's a it's a bit of a bit of
a pest to have to do the exported import
but for hardcore mappers we may they
might find this one they might find that
a perfectly reasonable workflow and in
our alpha testing it's born out that way
however how many folks here just like
they just go ahead and use sequel quick
show of hands alright so for you all we
have this use case hi I'm an analyst I
like bigquery I just wrote a query that
has a geospatial data type and the
result would you please let me view that
on a map and so to do that we're
actually launching to alpha as well
bigquery geophys which is a lightweight
mapping tool that you can use to go
ahead and compose a query here in the
window and then you run that query and
that it calls bigquery to run the query
populates the results here you tell it
which result which column you want to
draw and it drops it on to the map and
then you can do real-time styling now
this downloads those results all into
the browser's memory so sorry we don't
we don't need to watch the gif go around
again it downloads the results into the
browser's memory so it's not like an
infinite cache of geo data that you can
draw it's limited to about 2,000 points
or polygons however for the case where
you just want to see the result on a map
we thought this was a much better
experience then well honestly anything
else we could think of and I would like
to point out that the engineer mr. Don
mccurdy who did this is sitting right
here in the front row so thank you very
much Don
[Applause]
all righty two more things you got to
know before we get to the demo
trust me it's only two so BQ ml is the
one of the really big launches that
we've had here for bigquery it was
highlighted in the keynote earlier but
this fundamentally is the ability to
create models evaluate models and
predict on models all within sequels so
we've invented some new sequel verbs and
all inside the bigquery UI so gone other
days are needing to export data data to
GCS ingest it into tensor flow or cloud
ml engine or into you know spark ml or
whatever you can do it all inside of
bigquery so that simplifies life a lot
we're gonna use that in just a second
the other thing you need so like that's
one of the the basic building blocks the
other piece of information you need to
have before we get to the demo is who's
consuming this and what's the problem so
smart cities is a a data-driven
initiative to try to alleviate some of
the traffic or infrastructure congestion
problems that are plaguing cities not
just in the States but around the world
and so like growth and this is a really
significant thing right this is not just
us spending more time in traffic as we
go to and from work like you know
decreases in the ability of folks to
move around cities is materially
impacting accessibility to jobs
accessibility to opportunity
it creates incredibly high gradients and
housing prices which makes markets a
little bit less stable and it talks you
know and it speaks also to environmental
sustainability and the quality of life
that we have in our cities so it's a big
problem and by applying data and
analytics to it we might be able to use
much our infrastructure much more
efficiently
now the cynical among us or at least the
data cynical and I imagine there are
very few data cynics in this particular
audience given the the crew here but the
data cynics might ask like well you know
what you know what why don't we just
build more well Seattle that's where I
live
cannot handle a four hundred lane
highway
there's just not enough room so we have
to use data and analytics to do things
like optimizing like real time adaptive
spotlights on streets you know rideshare
is that data in analytics heavy heavy
application my favorite one on this list
ride share and flying cars all right so
all of these techniques are heavily
reliant on data and analytics and so we
have to produce these we have to produce
these technologies Google has to produce
these features so that companies like
geotab can help smart cities decide how
to use their infrastructure more wisely
and so we've covered a couple things
we've covered the launch right so be qml
be QGIS we covered the VIS tools we
covered the background information and
with that I will give up the stage and
let the main act come on on Bob thanks
everyone so before we get to the demo I
just want to explain a little bit about
who geotab is and what we do
so geotab is a global leader in the
telematics space we have an open
platform from fleet management so for
those of you that don't know what
telematics is it's connecting commercial
vehicles and reporting where they are
and other information about them so it's
kind of a nice coincidence that we're
surrounded by all these cool colorful
tires here and so we have 1.2 million
vehicles or over 1.2 million vehicles
driving around the world every single
day and that produces 3 billion rows of
data each and every day that we ingest
into bigquery an interesting thing that
we do at geotab is we have a patented
data reduction algorithm a curve based
logging algorithm that allows us to
minimize the amount of data so those 3
billion rows once they land in bigquery
we can explode those out by
interpolating and two really really
large usually ten fold data sets I was
gonna come up and explain a little bit
about the size of the data we have in
bigquery but I just found out from Chad
before this that the stat many of you
saw this morning the largest query ever
written in terms of rows was one of our
employees so 28 trillion rows which was
awesome so that's cool but we also
believe we have the richest dataset in
the telematics business and why do I say
that is because we're much much more
than just points on a map although
obviously we have no lack of points on a
map this is one day of geotab data in
order
America but we collect a whole host of
other information that's useful for
fleet management but also extremely
useful for Smart City applications so we
manufacture the device in the software
and on device we have an accelerometer
the accelerometer measures three axis
accelerometer movements and forward and
back so we can detect harsh breaking
incidence or hazardous incidents that
result from hard acceleration we can
have side to side movements so we can
tell if people are swerving around
objects or if there's corners that
people are taking too fast and maybe
they're blind corners or you need to add
a sign and op down allows us to monitor
road conditions so we can do things like
identify potholes or or bad road
conditions another interesting thing we
do is we actually reverse engineer data
from the vehicle itself and that
includes a lot of things that you'd
expect fault codes seatbelt usage engine
rpm but it includes some really really
cool things that you wouldn't think of
like ambient air temperature and outside
pressure and we can use those things to
generate hyperlocal roadside weather and
pressure maps and we also get windshield
wiper information and with 1.2 million
vehicles driving around we can actually
predict if it's snowing or raining just
by the activity of the windshield wipers
in various areas and we can combine all
of these things to generate driver
behavior profiles and tell if there's
areas in a city that are hazardous or
that need some attention because there's
accidents there and if you want to learn
some more about what we do at geotab we
actually just published a joint case
study with Google it's really really
good read I'll leave it there for the
folks on YouTube and check it out learn
a little bit more about geotab now when
Chad asked us to talk about some of the
stuff we did with GIS I wanted to
mention and make sure we talked about
this that geotab has been doing GIS and
bigquery for some time so we've been a
longtime bigquery customer and as you
can imagine most of our data has the
geospatial component so over the years
we've been developing ways to do
geospatial analysis in bigquery and one
of the coolest features of bigquery in
my opinion is the JavaScript PDF
functionality so we are able to use the
JavaScript functionality to bin our data
into geospatial buckets like s2 cells or
geohashes so what you're seeing here on
the right is a map of temperature
changes hyperlocal ones and as I've
learned in my short time here in San
Francisco the weather changes when you
change streets or turn corners and so
this is really really cool and we can do
boxes of 500 feet by 500 feet and
actually aggregate anonymize our data
and show it on a map and we can also do
things like create inline functions here
to do Hammerstein's distance so we've
been doing geospatial for some time but
the GIS functions accelerate this
development and really really allow us
to build smart city applications on top
of our already existing platform so that
math you saw before where we could been
eight into as two cells or we could you
know we could look at using geohashes at
D right now what we can do is we can
aggregate and anonymize and pull
statistics across arbitrary shapes so it
could be a Geo JSON file it could be a
shapefile and we can perform all of
those cool st underscore star functions
that Chad said rate within bigquery so
now we can do distance and intersection
and contains and all those cool things
so that map we had before where we were
looking at boxes on the earth was really
cool but we can also now just go out and
get some open data so I took an open
data set of neighborhoods here in San
Francisco and I can use an SD contains
and just find what the temperature is in
every single one of these neighborhoods
and we can do this with anything that we
have in our Big Data environment so now
we can look at which neighborhood has
the most accidents or the most hazardous
driving or we can look for hotspots of
idling and make an environmental impact
really really cool stuff that we can do
and what makes it even more powerful for
us is that every single smart city out
there or every aspiring smart city have
their data in shapefiles or geo JSON and
they also have geotab devices in every
single one of those cities so I'm going
to talk to you guys about a real-world
use case and we've been starting to
develop an application around this that
that builds upon our open platform that
involves driving pattern and driving
behavior and looking at it in front of a
school in New York so I'm sure a lot of
you have driven over these things in the
past and so let's imagine for a second
that you're dropping your children off
at school in New York City and you
notice that in your opinion there's some
people driving through in front of the
school very very quickly and so you make
a call into 3-1-1 and you voice your
concern you're concerned citizen and so
what might happen today
if someone would go out and install
pneumatic tubes across the road and
conduct a study and they're measuring
the volume of traffic that comes across
those tubes and the speed that they're
traveling and they collect the data for
a few weeks they bring it back they
analyze it and then they get back to you
the concerned citizen with the results
and what we think is that now that we
have these geospatial functions we can
spend a few minutes and do a virtual
study with a virtual pneumatic tube
using the new functions in V QGIS so
before we get to the demo I'm just gonna
do a couple a little under the covers
things to showcase how we use some of
the geospatial functions so the first
thing we wanted to do for this demo was
we don't need to look at 1.2 million
vehicles to figure out what the traffic
looks like in front of a school in New
York so how can we filter that data in
the past maybe we were to use the
bounding box and we would have tried to
use a lotta two longitude but now we can
go to the NYC open data portal and we
can pull down the data set of school
zones and we know in this case we're
looking at the neighborhood charter
school in district 6 of New York City
so let's filter by district 6 in New
York City so you can see here we would
pull our GPS records in which would
contain all of that traffic information
speed cool stuff that we can get that
you can't get from a pneumatic strip
like types of vehicles that are driving
over the strip etc and we would use an
SD contains and what I thought was
actually especially cool about this was
the NYC open data portal had the data
sitting in a CSV so there was no
transformation I just downloaded
uploaded and ran my query pretty awesome
cool now the second thing we need to do
is we need to understand which vehicles
are actually crossing this fake
pneumatic tube and the way we do that is
by leveraging the lag and lead operators
in bigquery so you can imagine as you're
driving your vehicle along you're
dropping GPS points on the road and what
we're doing is we're taking those GPS
points you can see in red and we're
connecting the lag point with the
current point to make a line so we're
making thousands and thousands of these
lines as they're dropping their GPS
points and what's important to us is
which of those lines intersects with the
fake tube that we've drawn in the ground
and so you can see here our sub query is
looking at traffic and so here's where
we're making those lines so we're using
an ST make line function and we're
taking the lag point and the
point that we have sitting in bigquery
and we're making thousands if not
millions of these tiny little lines and
down below here we're using the
intersect function to look at which of
those intersect with the line that we
drew on the map so we can get a true
representative of the vehicles that are
actually crossing in front of this
school
so with that I'll jump out and do a
quick demo so what you can see here is
an add-in that we've made that lives
within our open portal so we have
hundreds if not thousands of these
add-ins now that are built upon our
portal we build some of those ourselves
and that's what we have here and if I
left myself a pin because there's no way
in front of all of you I was going to be
able to find the school that I wanted to
go to so what we have here is the
neighborhood charter school that we were
talking about and if i zoom in my
complaint as a citizen of New York was
that I feel like one hundred and forty
fifth Street the traffic is just moving
too quickly so what I can do is I can
come over here and I can create this
virtual pneumatic tube I'm gonna draw it
right across 145th Street whoops and
once I have the tube drawn I can run the
traffic study and what we're doing is
we're going out to bigquery jad you got
got any advice here that's not supposed
to happen that's not so what's happening
now while Chad's logging in is we're
going out to bigquery and we're looking
for all those vehicles that are crossing
that line thanks Chad and we're pulling
back statistics so now as an employee of
the city or the municipality I can get
some information that I can give back to
the citizen so I can see and I know that
in New York the average speed or the
speed limit in front of a school should
be 15 miles an hour so on the surface it
doesn't look too bad if I break it down
by hour of day it looks like people are
pretty well behaved but if you look at
these average speed bands over here I
can see 16% of the people are going
between 25 and 30 another three and a
half are going over 30 miles an hour so
there are actually some twenty twenty
percent of the people that are speeding
through this area quite substantially so
there may be something to that I also
get a breakdown of the types of vehicles
that we see the average speed and the
trends and I also notice that Saturday
is a particularly bad day people are
driving much much quicker on their
Saturday
now of course kids aren't in school that
day which is great but still something
to be concerned about the other thing we
did is we used the district six to go
out and pull in information that we
already calculated geotab for smart
cities
around hazardous driving areas and Road
impediments so we can see here the green
represents areas that are hazardous so
that's where we see a lot of harsh
braking events are swerving or accidents
happening on aggregate across all of our
vehicles so well in front of the school
is not too bad just down the street at
the corner is pretty hazardous and this
could cause issues that back up traffic
or you know maybe that's a path that a
lot of these students are walking to
school and in blue we meant we measure
the road conditions so good news in
front of the school is pretty good over
here maybe could use some attention so
you can see the kind of things that we
can do using the GIS functions and
what's awesome about this as a developer
is that it's just a select statement
there's no other work that needs to be
done and all of our data gets to stay
within bigquery whereas in the past we
might have had to pull it out and then
compare it with shape files everything
right now happens great inside bigquery
so that's it for my demo I'm gonna pass
things over to Daniel who's going to
show you a much much cooler demo
combining be GIS and geek UML thank you
[Applause]
cool
all right so I'm gonna talk to you about
yeah combining BQ ml with the bigquery
GIS functions so for those of you who
kind of missed the spotlight session
earlier which she seems like it was most
of you we kind of demoed the tool here
which I'm going to get into more details
about but essentially on the left here
is the current hazardous areas for the
city of Chicago and Bob kind of
mentioned the accelerometer data that we
get and we can kind of aggregate those
over time to see where there are
particular problem areas where we're
consistently seen relative and kind of
scaled to the proportion of vehicles
that are driving through that area and
the volume of traffic where there's
problems and patterns of hazardous
driving behavior and on the right is
actually a prediction of where these
hazardous areas are expected to be based
on predicted weather conditions and it's
gonna be really cool I'm gonna walk you
through how we actually built this demo
and all of it happened within bigquery
as Bob mentioned we never have to leave
using the new functions so as a data
scientist I love playing with machine
learning models obviously but now that I
get to use kind of these GIS tools as
well and I'm combined with them we can
do some pretty awesome and powerful
things that were really difficult before
so just stepping back a moment I mean
Bob kind of already mentioned this
briefly but I just wanna sort of talk
again about how we actually calculate
these hazardous areas so we've got our
devices in all of these vehicles and
we're constantly monitoring the
accelerometer and so the types of harsh
driving behavior that we're looking for
things like harsh braking rapid
acceleration harsh cornering you know
relative to kind of the speed of the
street where we wouldn't expect some
that kind of thing to be happening and
we're also gonna be detecting accidents
constantly as well we aggregate these
over time and when we look at the
accelerometer events beyond a certain
threshold from multiple vehicles in this
area we can start to classify it as
hazardous and we're constantly
calculating these areas you know every
single day globally across the entire
planet and storing them in bigquery
daily and so if you're the city of the
Chicago obviously you don't care about
all of this global data you're just
gonna want to filter out the subset of
areas that are relevant to you in the
city and using these cool GIS tools they
can just upload a shapefile to us and
then we can run a simple select
statement and pull out all of our data
you know within that red bounding box
area for the city of Chicago which is
super cool and a lot easier than what I
had to do before so before I mean we're
still doing this
stuff I would have had to do things like
you know cash a table that had reversed
geocoded us to cells or geohashes look
for you know within certain bounds that
kind of thing but now it's a one-liner
which is fantastic but uh what i think
is even cooler then kind of aggregating
this information over time is what we
can do in terms of predicting the future
so I mean cities are obviously really
interested in what's happening right now
in terms of hazardous areas and they're
gonna want to know the severity of those
things and how to prioritize roadwork
and maybe improve signage add things
like you know speed bumps and things
like that in the in the road but what's
more important is actually being
proactive and addressing you know safety
concerns before they actually start to
hurt people especially in front of
things like schools and so I thought a
really cool use case would be use some
of the public data that's already
available in bigquery to kind of build a
model around weather and see how if it's
gonna be a particularly snowy day or if
it's gonna be a really rainy day or
we're losing visibility how is that
gonna impact traffic around the city and
like the city can maybe say okay we're
gonna have a particularly harsh winter
with a lot more traffic volume than
we're used to what's gonna happen and
what areas don't need to address before
that becomes a problem
so stepping back a little bit first I
need to actually do kind of a sanity
check to see if that's something that's
even gonna be possible so I took the
last two years of our hazardous driving
area for the city of Chicago kind of
started to parse it out by weather
conditions and looked was there any
measurable impact on our data from
weather on kind of like the relative
severity of hazardous driving across the
city and so I used a variety of the j-s
functions but essentially here the st
snap to grid functionality to bend
things across the city and then
calculate the average severity score and
correlate it with weather and produce
some of these cool maps that you see
here on the screen and so you're going
to notice they're a little bit jiggled
around there so after doing the
aggregation with the esti snap the grade
functionality I just shifted them around
by the average latitude and longitude
for each of those sections where we're
historically observing hazardous driving
areas so that we know we can tell the
city specifically where the problem is
on the road so they can go and address
that
I mean after producing these maps my
first thought was cool this is awesome I
can immediately see a big difference
between the winter in the summer and
these particular days here so it's
probably something that I can do with
you know a model that I'm gonna be
building then bigquery to start to
predict these things before they happen
and see what kind of the relationships
are mathematically between weather and
his driving areas I mean one of the cool
things that was sort of not obvious to
me that that jumped out from this was on
the left you see obviously there's a lot
more hazardous driving and hazardous
areas in the winter than the summer but
the highways actually are proportionally
less dangerous than the neighborhoods of
the city which was a little bit
counterintuitive to me
so you're promised possibly more likely
to get into an accident going to or from
the highway then you know actually
driving on the highway just because of
the amount of harsh driving relative to
the volume of traffic that's going
through that area so great this seems
viable and historical as data is really
interesting but how can we actually use
that to start to make some predictions
about the future so we're gonna dive in
a little bit under the hood into how we
actually made the spotlight session
happen so yeah it's really easy to pull
in all of these things we can aggregate
you know with some simple esti functions
the hazardous areas for the city over
the past few weeks or the past few
months or whatever particular historical
period they might be interested in maybe
filter that by severity score and give
them an idea where they might want to
prioritize their road work and for a
city this is super cool but I mean if
I'm a city planner I want to address
things again proactively before they
happen so what about tomorrow what about
tomorrow if it's snowing what about
tomorrow if it's snowing and there's low
visibility there's all sorts of
conditions that could happen tomorrow
and maybe you could go back and find an
exact historical correlate for what
happened with that but that doesn't take
into account and if your projected
traffic volumes you know your speeds on
these streets change over time the
weather patterns change over time a lot
of things are changing and so you don't
understand the relationships between
those I can't just look at historical
data I need to be able to predict the
future and so that's what we're gonna do
using just be qml and we never have to
live leave bigquery to do any of this
which is the coolest part and so we can
join the data that we have our
historical driving data with all of the
public data I mentioned that bigquery
already has available for daily weather
they have this going back decades for
thousands of weather stations across
North America and there's several of
them that happened to be around Chicago
so I can interpolate between all of
those and get you know roughly for that
day you know things like the average
temperature broken down by that grid
that we did with sess t snap to grid
functionality I can get the max
temperature the min temperature the
visibility for that day the total amount
of precipitation whether it was foggy
whether there was funnel cloud formation
for tornadoes all of this cool things
and then I can use all these newbie qml
tools which have been announced several
times today to start to train on this
data and so in just a few lines of code
that you see here I'm able to train a
model that's gonna be doing all of this
prediction for me so a few lines of code
really simple really powerful so in
reality actually created over 300
features for this model which are
various kind of a transformed versions
of weather inputs combinations things
like temperature scaled by visibility
and functional transformations and
things like that
unfortunately that wouldn't fit on the
slide and Chad won't let me do it anyway
so this is the simplified version of
that so if you just sort of use your
imagination and the temperature
visibility snow rain and fog here
actually reflective of much more complex
features but there's a whole lot of
things going on here
that you see on the slide and there's
actually even more going on behind the
scenes which I'm gonna also going to
talk about and which I think is the kind
of really key part of what makes BQ
Mel's so powerful and what was gonna
really make it powerful for analysts as
well who maybe don't have as much data
science background and so in the first
line we're just telling bigquery to
create a new model simple enough and
then we can provide some options for
bigquery and how it's gonna actually fit
this model and what kind of you know
hyper parameters we want to use to do
that but the only actual required things
here are the model type and the labels
that I want to predict we can specify a
whole lot of other things to those such
as like the minimum relative progress
the learning rate that I wanted to use
if I wanted to do regularization what
type of regularization the maximum
number of training iterations the
learning rate strategy all of these
things I can tell if they create to do
but I don't have to because big worries
gonna handle all of that for me and do
this kind of hyper parameter
optimization for me victories
automatically gonna create a chain test
split of my data I can manually specify
that if I want to but again I don't have
to it's gonna do the Train test split
for me it's gonna set an initial
learning rate and it's gonna adjust it
during gradient descent algorithm weekly
I don't have to worry about that either
one of the coolest things especially
when you have over 300 features is that
it's gonna Center and normalize all of
my features to zero mean and unit
standard deviation without me having to
do any of that saves me a heck of a lot
of typing it's also going to
automatically one-hot encode all of my
categorical variables I don't have to do
that either and I think there's gonna be
some additional functionality soon that
you can automatically bucket eyes things
as well which is fantastic and because
it's automatically creating this
training test
for me it's actually keeping track of
the loss by iteration so I can
immediately go as soon as this models
been trained and quickly check for
overfitting which again is fantastic and
I don't have to code any of that behind
the scenes I can do this with just a few
lines of code which is fantastic and
just to reiterate all of this is
happening inside big hurry I still
haven't even left the same browser tab
that I opened to begin with which is
fantastic so this particular model that
I'm gonna actually show you the demo for
I trained on about 600,000 training
examples from the query for training the
model only took about 15 minutes and if
you remember I mentioned I've got over
300 features let's over 180 million data
points used for training that Vickery is
able to parse through and fit a model to
you in under 15 minutes which is
fantastic using nothing but sequel code
so oK you've you know I'm take a breath
for a moment there's a lot of things
happening in that slide but okay you're
the analyst you set up this model you've
gone you've got your coffee you come and
sit down and Wow okay the models already
trained fantastic let's start making
predictions but not quite is it actually
any good luckily this functionality is
already built into bigquery for us so
again super simple just a few lines of
code that you can kind of see here and
they're rather self-explanatory on the
slide but I still haven't left the same
tab I can do all of my evaluation off of
tables that the queries already created
when I trained this model we've already
got what we need for a basic overfitting
check because it did that train test
split for me and created that loss table
but we can also easily use this evaluate
statement to pull out some summary
statistics like the mean squared error
of the model the r-squared scored the
percentage of explained variance and I
can see if you know we're on the market
we need to maybe go back to our data
cleaning step our future generation or
selection stage and train again luckily
for us I've already done all this dirty
work and we can just skip right ahead to
making some cool predictions about where
the dangerous areas are gonna be so
after the last couple slides this is
probably gonna sound familiar but we can
do all of our predictions with just a
few lines of code and I still haven't
left the same open browser tab it's
really really cool so the syntax here is
almost identical to the ML evaluate
statement that we were running earlier
we basically just passed in the model
that we've already created and trained
and hopefully as you know I diligent
data scientist or analyst you've already
gone through and done the appropriate
evaluation to make sure that your models
actually you know predicting something
and explaining a appropriate amount of
variance that you can use it for
something
and so I've done that and so what is
this actually gonna look like and how
could a city use this to actually do
something you know actionable with this
data and so I'm gonna kind of jump into
the demo and show you what that app
actually looks like so this was from the
screenshot that I showed you at the
beginning of this section on the left
here just to reiterate was the current
hazardous driving areas in Chicago this
is real data by the way all of this so
this is the current hazardous driving
areas in the city of Chicago that we
measured and aggregated over the last
couple of weeks so you can see that
particular areas of the city
specifically in the south of Chicago are
kind of dangerous to be driving around
right now and you know a city might want
to zoom in on these areas and figure out
exactly where these problems are and
address them but as I'm trying to
reiterate it's better to be proactive
than reactive and addressing these kinds
of concerns and so let's say that it's
you know coming up to the fall and it's
gonna be a particularly a cold snowy day
and let's drop the temperature down a
little bit so let's say it's gonna be I
don't know maybe 31 degrees on a
particular day and there's a lot of snow
so maybe I'll drop down the visibility a
little bit we'll say that it's snowing
and let's say it's the holiday season
and people are really excited to get out
and do their shopping and more people
are on the road than usual let's say
maybe traffic volume is 20% higher than
it usually is so let's run the
predictive analysis and see what the
model thinks is gonna be the the
dangerous areas in the city of Chicago
for that particularly snowy cold day
with a lot of traffic boom so the map
looks really different so some of the
areas that were hazardous before are
still hazardous so great I mean the city
definitely knows now to prioritize those
areas but what's really cool is that
areas in kind of the top left here and
in the north of the city which weren't
dangerous before actually predicted to
get quite hazardous on this day so if a
city is just basing you know their
actions for fixing you know Road
conditions on the historical data
they're gonna miss a lot of these areas
that can become quite dangerous with
different weather conditions and so if
we actually zoom in on a particular area
here that I found before when looking
through the data one of these predicted
dangerous areas is right next to a
school
so you looking at the store achill data
the city's not gonna know that there's
this dangerous problem right in front of
a school and so with this cool tool we
can actually use our little google
person and jump down here and see what's
happening so we drop down a little bit
ahead of where this hazardous area is
happening to look around we can see the
school there which is cool and actually
if you notice up in the distance there's
a student crosswalk up there which is
you know great does
good signage for for safe areas but if
we look around here we actually see that
the bike racks are way down here next to
this alleyway so the students are
probably coming in and out of this
alleyway and if we step over here a
little bit
we noticed there's no stop signs and no
signage on this alleyway either there's
no speed bumps or nothing so the
hazardous area is happening right before
this alleyway here and the nearest
signage is several hundred feet up the
road near this crossing sign but it
looks like most of the students are
actually crossing here so the city might
want to come out and maybe think about
putting some speed humps here or some
additional signage or maybe some mirrors
around these corners and addressing this
problem that wouldn't otherwise be
obvious based on their current
historical data so hopefully you found
that interesting I found it super cool
to play with these new tools and kind of
build these models out on never having
to lead they create and we're able to
kind of train this this model on this
data you know the actual model trains in
15 minutes but even going through all of
the featured renovation and the ability
to quickly iterate through you know
training and evaluating within the
bigquery environment enable me to put
this model together in a matter of weeks
which is really quick turnaround for
something that's powerful so with that
I'm gonna turn it over back to you a
Chad thank you alright so that was that
was exceptionally cool and I did want to
touch on the the timing so you know we
reached out we've been working together
for a while but we reached out to you to
talk about like hey can you know I think
there's good material for a demo for
next year and that was really only two
months ago and so like you know getting
spun up on the GIS features getting spun
up on B qml crafting the thing and then
producing that awesome demo that's like
not just a demo that's gonna be fun for
us like the city planners in Chicago are
gonna love that anyway so I just wanted
to give it up for geotab both the
speakers here and the folks back at the
home office who worked on that you guys
did a fantastic job thank you
alrighty um so this is the wrap-up right
this is the third act of our of our
three act play here and I just wanted to
review a little bit we're not going to
go through everything but right we we
talked about what the launches were we
talked about how geotab is able to craft
that not just into a cool demo but like
into a product that they can then you
know like these are new product lines
that
and other companies that want to
leverage us can then generate for smart
city applications or like what's also
getting me excited about this right the
third act isn't the end right there's an
encore right there our ring studies for
retail ride-sharing applications IOT
media studying das and MSAs
like using this using these new features
inside of bigquery actually opens
bigquery up to enormous new volumes of
work which is you know what we're all
about right we want to make our tool
useful to as many people as possible in
as many different domains as possible so
that actually brings me to a final
analogy here there is quite a lot of
geospatial data that's already resident
in bigquery right Bob was talking that
the geo tab has been doing GIS work in
bigquery for quite a while but there
there are lots of columns in bigquery
tables that you know have latitude or
longitude as the column header so the
data in some respects is already there
certainly the data is in other data
stores that folks haven't brought to
bigquery because we didn't support
latitudes and longitudes and this is the
analogy with Street View so what was it
back about 2006 2007 Google went through
the world's streets and took pictures of
you know facades you know Street
pictures like this and just logged where
they were in the world you know we we
made we made the Street View home
database what we weren't able to do with
the time that we collected that data was
in detail look into those pictures and
extract information like where are the
traffic signs what are the street
numbers what are the retail
establishments that are at that location
we couldn't do that
since then we've developed the ml
technology to look into these images and
pull that information out and we've even
productized those as you know cloud ml
api's and that's generated an enormous
opportunity for us and for our customers
in that you know we can now we can now
look into these data sets and provide
metadata on like views of the stores
these are the establishments that are at
this location and so we've actually been
able to generate a lot more value off of
this trove of images that we collected a
decade ago and that's the state that I
think we're in right now in terms of
geospatial data in bigquery people have
been collecting to you a spatial data
people even been storing it in bigquery
but they've lacked the tools to really
go in and dig out cool stuff like what
Bob and Daniel showed so I'm very very
very excited about this and I think
we're at an inflection point for this
type of work in bigquery
you
[Music]